xoxo you know I want us to do ages
spits emboss freelance we're just like
back to back just back to back don't got
the drink in me yeah off the dome
straight off the tap focus obviously you
say it I say a topic and see if we can
run sign obviously back in the day -
bare copper body did you spit bars in my
nature spit bars back in the day if you
didn't know get to know I didn't my
alias was Flo FL oh I used to write some
[ __ ] bars boy without what I remember
and this was in second school this was
like so I think I'm sitting in this
party before but if I have him I went to
three secretary schools yeah seven I
went to send dancers College which is a
Rugby School in Catford southeast London
moved to Nigeria for two years Wow Wow
if you didn't see that
he's trying to pour tequila and shot
glass because we're gonna do sip sips if
you're never done a sip sip before
you'll learn today you did even shake
the pineapple bro why do I need to shake
it cuz the sediments gonna be good at
bottom
it's gonna be all the weather why is
that funny because it's gonna be at the
bottom
you know what I mean no I don't want a
light pineapple I want that stick
now you're gonna [ __ ] that's your one by
the way okay yeah cool
what was I saying [ __ ] I say you went
to a Rugby School then you went to some
others
oh yeah you know sorry to cut you off my
not real quick yeah do you know how I
know London is are sick every sport mmm
because you went to a rugby school huh
what's a rugby square screwed up
specialized specialised in rugby their
sport was rugby it was a private school
oh we didn't have schools that out
that's my one I I categorically said
that's my when you said you know I'll
have sip sip why because I'm drunk
before I even try it you know what I
mean it the fumes you know I mean it
must yes you look at I love that you
just said that's your shot and am I
ready to take it so yeah I went to went
to a rugby school board a private school
year seven went on I drew in your 8 to10
and then when I came back in year ten
that's when I started writing properly
like I say right in property I'm a
[ __ ] musician but that's when I
started hmm because that was the culture
back then everyone was growing up a riot
buzz and then that's yeah I was too
embarrassed to do it well my boys are
doing now we're doing that why are you
embarrassed is it because you didn't
feel like you were good or an alias did
you have a tag back I might now I had a
tag but not really like I was was I
suntan Superman
that was me boy what was that that
people just kind of called you that no
one called me - I call myself that fam
Sun Tan
Superman Sun tanned Sun tanned Superman
why why did you call yourself that I
don't know I just heard it somewhere and
I thought that looks that sounds good
that was my MSN name I was obviously was
flow some I thinking could have been
flown to UK six all my boys had tags I
didn't have things like that cheers my G
tequila sip sip after your story we'll
get into what tequila sip sip is these
shots a big chili Oh first one in a
minute especially with the represent Oh
first one in a minute that was delicious
anyway continue so yeah in year 10
that's when I started you can have to
move the team closer to G just turn on
my funny it's up is all the way up yeah
and you're telling us when I first
started writing bars because that's what
that's what was the hype in seconds yeah
yeah we used to have 2005/6 I remember I
remember when the transition this is
funny I remember when the transition
went from if I see pool people you're
out your lunch break yeah and I'm seeing
everyone sprint into the canteen yeah
I'm like it's a scrap yeah and you'd go
in there and people are fighting yeah
and then one day everyone's running in
there a couple minor clashes yeah I
remember the first time I seen it and I
was way too ya know just exchanging boss
[ __ ] is this broth yeah and then I go
coop but now I never used to write [ __ ]
I just how do I explain it mmm it just
was never me yeah and I would have been
forcing it I would never not force and
it just wasn't me he just wasn't think
it was as much culture appropriate
outside of London it wasn't as much but
everyone in my you was trying to beg it
as well but for me like how do I explain
it right now if I was a kid right now
I'll probably be more drawn to it
because my whole life I've just been
about the funny yeah I just care about
[ __ ] funny yeah yeah but when I was
coming up mmm like people writing lyrics
and so far that now will be more
inclined to be funny with it yeah when
we were growing up you couldn't be jokey
with it yeah you have to be straight
yeah yeah there was no there was no jest
or comic side as great as a front
straight crud you had something for your
mum coming for you
yeah brough like I was I was all about
I'm I've never been about fake
seriousness okay I feel you okay he died
you know so if it was more about if I
could have done a comedy thing I would
have been bang on it yeah back then it
just wasn't an option I think of a topic
let's go alright anything
let's see if you can do it because I
know this is gonna so it'll be terrible
right cooking oh you say about an awful
lot all right you just got back and
forth right you have to go you go you go
you go you cook in all right I'm
whipping up so wait what kind of temp
are we going that's the thing are we
going you yeah give me a little not too
fast then it yeah yeah think about it
say no more
Oh in filmies built-in that's why I say
you go first so I can go to your temple
all right you know I mean okay you pick
a temper I'll try and keep up like a
temple okay
we don't have the picket supper but just
go you go you go comes natural all right
cooking I whipping up something hot so
unique is that didn't it and yeah yeah
we put up something hot did do the next
one to catch up i whipping up something
hot in a saucepan not in a pot calling
up my favorite thought something some
cool I'm afraid of it thought yeah come
around see what I've got yeah I feel
like we need to be we need to be needed
to be noisy mad but I'm just picking up
is big enough I'm feeling it I feel come
run see what God she's come run seed at
all
she already knows mine ain't no fool the
way I back it out I make her smack it
out and they're gonna put it on him
after she draws drooling all over my
plate it's using up that sing like a
steak has a better feeling of a sirloin
but when when she comes run I'm hittin
her loins mmm
smashing it straight from the back she's
a full meal not a little snack no snack
straight butthole food a [ __ ] Sigrid
it's a whole need this is so jokes I'm
sorry if you're listening to discuss of
ways to raise the five minutes of your
day
she's a ting to me but I'm her dude
when she comes around this all nude all
nude no color right I was dead I can't
think of any that was so that so was I
lost but when she comes to my mind it
was all news playing old games in the
bedsheets lane on the front I'm a spread
cheeks her brain makes me excel no
spreadsheets punchline that's it all
right another sip sip that was it five
minutes of your time to get to that
punchline was so yeah for those who
don't know want to get to know
tequila sip sip so you take a shot of
tequila follow it down [ __ ] the salt
[ __ ] the lemon or lime whatever straight
you follow it down chase it down with a
pineapple juice no the trick is the
reason why we call it a sip sip listen
is because when your neck in the pan of
would use you can't take it like a shot
you have to take it down in as many sips
as humanly possible and I swear to god
you will finish a whole bottle of
tequila by yourself and you won't even
know yeah you weren't gag you want yak
you won't get those weird horrible
tingles down you good if you do it wrong
and if you do it wrong you don't [ __ ]
up yeah because it will pay you back
twice as hard yeah cuz everyone that
I've taught this say oh [ __ ] I can't do
it and they're like they're gag is
because they've done it completely wrong
you have to shut and [ __ ] neck have
buffing buff in your hand one shot
killing one hand one show up I don't
reduce in the other hand once you back
the tequila the sips it needs to be
right there holy but shorty Gaza Leah
and it cleanses the whole palate
it's a paladin for some reason it's
called a crate David don't know why if
you open dictionaries I just called a
great David well it's it's it yeah this
is a title for today sip sip sip sip sip
sip
let's go round two baby it's good vibes
good vibes only shit's and gigs [ __ ]
gigs I was good ice-cold pineapple is
amazing
I'm actually so proud of that XL bar oh
yeah I'm so proud of that except I was
Lea
I can't wait ELISA back today if someone
practice will get back will get better
so you are thinking reminiscing yeah
almost yeah I didn't even know if I'm on
camera for this [ __ ]
you am i reminisce him almost [ __ ] boy
ism mmm the good the bad and the funny I
like that that's probably the time
actually I like that yeah [ __ ] boy ISM
what like how do I explain it what is
considered a [ __ ] boy or no I know what
can what's considered a [ __ ] boy yeah
it's more about every guy goes through a
phase way he's so proud to be a [ __ ] boy
yeah 100% he won't call himself a [ __ ]
ball yeah Netaji
yeah it was of a G but like with with
great power comes great responsibility
yeah that's where I can say it yeah
because being a [ __ ] boy being a
lacklustre [ __ ] boy I will [ __ ] you yeah
big time mmm I'm a prime example yeah me
my I know out of all my friends I wasn't
even the biggest [ __ ] boy yeah but
because I've had so many repercussions
from it yeah I seem like I was yeah yeah
yeah yeah
I don't you mean like my numbers not
even that high yeah granted it was high
for a very small amount
everyone's kind of like you've had that
same phase where it's more about time is
high zero repercussions yeah I know
other friends that have been doing the
same thing for years yeah and they're in
the thousands probably now yeah zero
repercussions I've just had crazy [ __ ]
after crazy [ __ ] after this and that
and now
and it's [ __ ] funny and we'll share a
couple stories but yeah what do you
think it is about the appeal of being a
fuck-boy
I feel like is it from from a female
perspective or no from your perspective
my perspective where the appeal about
being a fuck-boy
no one ever grows up and says I want to
be a [ __ ] but you never think you would
be a fuck-boy it just kind of happens do
you know I mean yeah yeah so my I think
my [ __ ] boy phase was probably only
recently like not not recently like last
month but like recently but in a last
couple of years yeah I mean I feel like
it happened when I moved up here because
the freedom and the not the freedom the
accessibility yes on tap in tsunami it
was instant obviously when I lived in
London I lived one obviously when I
lived in London
I live with my rents so it wasn't as
easy to get girls especially back to
your top six or whatever yeah yeah as it
is no because I don't live with my
parents I live a lot more online if I
live away from my parents so you kind of
fall into that phase of oh [ __ ] this is
what life is when you're outside that
realm of mmm you know rules and
regulations you just do what you want
you just let loose you just let loose
but the thing is more time girls well
some girls know or necessarily
understand the fact that you're a
quote-unquote [ __ ] boy yeah but they
[ __ ] with it because the same way I'm
not looking for something serious it's
the same way they're not looking for
something serious Oh 100% so that's the
good in it 100% the good in it it's bad
in it is when they're looking for
something a bit more and I'm [ __ ]
three other girls yeah not necessary
that's a fact but like that's an example
the bad you know I mean yeah and it's
then hard what to them you are now a
fuck-boy because you are [ __ ] around
having fun while playing game playing
the game and playing the field
but to them you would always be classed
as a fuck-boy 100% and it that's why it
comes with what's the word how can i
phrase it it comes with the how can I
say it
it's [ __ ] how can I put in a word we can
say say [ __ ] being a father it comes to
this consequences wife yeah like I said
the good the bad the ugly you know [ __ ]
wait comes with his consequences so you
have to roll with the punches and check
on take it on the chin yeah 100% the
funny side of it is the stories that
come from being a quote-unquote flat
Boyle so I've I [ __ ] girls or has sex
with girls that I'm not necessarily
seeing and then on si what you see in me
and it's just it's just sex it just went
obviously this is in the past it's just
sex it's just fun and they know it's
just sex is just fun so there was one
time I tried to obviously everyone knows
the story I said it like episode 3 well
I was high and when see would it be
cooler are the white neighborhood who
was naked with a good break you with the
good brains yeah but the thing is I
don't think she's she thinks I'm a [ __ ]
boy because we both wanted the same
thing at the same time I mean yeah so in
actual fact that's the that's good yeah
yeah the bad obviously I've explained
about girls wanting more than a guy's
the funny I'm trying to think of a
actual example that I've been through
that's funny oh this is actually this
was before I moved to money actually mmm
so in 2015 you're so good no I know
because I remember scenarios I complete
the reason why I'm so good in the years
is because I know when I moved some
money yeah so in 2015
I've turned were you now twenty twenty
other thing I then tell like 25 or
something
or 24 car member at a birthday I'm
borrowing Shoreditch yes it I'd birthday
our bar so you didn't go I think it was
the one time I didn't go to your
birthday in it I pissed on missed it so
at that birthday I had a girl I used to
see a girl I was seeing a girl that
wanted to see me
ex ghost and a woman ex and to me I was
in my element was my birthday or
something fun so to me it was not
necessarily funny but I didn't think
anything
wrong of the situation do you know I
mean yeah so to some girls it would have
automatically seemed like I'm a fuck-boy
yeah but in hindsight not necessarily it
was funny but it didn't dawn on me this
situation I was in
yeah but to me I feel like I thrive off
those situations anywhere done said it
before mmm do you not I mean it's weird
to me because I like I like pressure I
thought I wonder pressure yeah I love to
thrive under pressure it just it makes
me feel if I come out of it unscathed
yes it's a times if you come of it
unscathed be [ __ ] I was a thrill yeah
I'm doing it deader that was a thrill do
you know I mean it's Sofia it's so weird
and so funny boy oh man that's that's me
what about you mine is like how do I
explain it mine actually went on in in
retrospect mine is like a combination of
quite sad not sad things but in terms of
like did good yeah good is very small
for me yeah in terms that I've told you
before like I can go out on a night out
in my single days and stuff like that
and I've always told you'd like that
goes there's times where I've gone out
well we've gone out or whatever yeah
I've met a girl she's attractive she
thinks I'm attractive
we flirted all night dance whatever then
we go back to hers go back to mine we
[ __ ] whatever I've always said to you
the actual sex part mm is never as a
slight good as a taste just the initial
once being wanted yeah just like as soon
as I know 100% she's down to [ __ ] yeah
it's boring it's boring yeah for me
those are not every time but a lot of
the time yeah like it's not necessary
the sex that ever did it for me it was
more about the excitement of like oh
[ __ ] this person thinks I'm [ __ ]
attractive yeah I think she's [ __ ]
attractive we got mad tension going on
and see what happens I see what happens
and then you find out she's like oh you
coming back and then you're like oh more
time I've said yes because I'm polite
yeah if I was a savage more time I'd
been a hell no cause I get FOMO as well
someone having fun yeah these men are
having a sick time and
I'm just [ __ ] okay I've had sex yeah
like it's for sex is fantastic but
sometimes being with your boys is
amazing anyway so that was the good that
was the only good part about me for
being the fat boy for me was knowing
that being wanted and stuff like that
from a complete stranger because when
it's a complete stranger you don't have
to rely on your intellect or your your
your wit although you don't know you
don't know you can anyone you want some
meat and then I want to [ __ ] this guy
yeah and you know oh hell yes that's
that's decent the bad I've had too much
bad too I'm gonna skip the bad for now
and they all come back to come back to
take the shot after you say the bad hmm
god damn
yeah so the funny and another things all
shits over - bit on your couch for me as
well with being a [ __ ] boy it sounds
weird because I had a lot of not a lot
of friends but obviously had you guys
might basically people who don't mind my
[ __ ] boy season was straight in uni
mmm-hmm I went through a faith and few
had will there was a phase in uni I
don't know what happened but lightning
struck and I was untouchable untouchable
I used to was I sound like a complete
and utter [ __ ] felon right now I
don't care go a little tequila at me
let's go with it I sound like such a
prick but it's true you man you might be
looking on camera now faking this
[ __ ] a [ __ ] but trust me there was a
time in uni where your boy James was
cleaning the [ __ ] cleaning up I could do
no wrong
mop bucket and all Easter sir was it
Monday night Monday night huh Monday and
Wednesday if I was desperate cuz
Wednesday was quiet yeah Wednesday was
white night as well that's when the
rugby man yeah Monday was was our
I was in my element found me if we had
used to go there and we we knew the
doorman yeah yeah cute what's the cute
so we used to slide straight in and
straight to the bar get a drink have a
bit of a giggle and then bang your boy
was on the dance floor scouting yeah I
was straight down in fact I'm pretty I
am pretty sure I thought that different
girl every week for like three months
like every week we go to bang you go
bang Luger I was bullet untouchable and
it was the best it was it was a weird
time in my life because even as I said
at the time like I was more about
wanting to be wanted but it's sad to say
that even then the only reason I enjoyed
it was the oh yeah the only reason I
enjoyed it was because I knew it would
be funny now yeah I knew there would be
a time in our lives in the future where
we could look back at this and laugh so
you did it for the story I did it for
the story and I did say so many things
when we were younger just for the
[ __ ] story yeah and not that I wanted
to do it then it is so many times where
I've slept with girls or done stuff for
anything and there's all for the story
yeah and yes the story is [ __ ] great
and yes I was right we do laugh or buy
it now but at the time it was something
that I didn't even want to do yeah for
some reason I just knew it would be
funny in the future yeah so I went
through with it yeah and then in
retrospect it's not what the [ __ ] were
you doing you do is [ __ ] you were
[ __ ] goes you didn't even want to
[ __ ] because you knew it'd be funny in
the future yeah um I guess if you flip
it back again then it was worth doing
because I'm enjoying it now yeah ten
years down the line away like it was
never it was never really about the
enjoyment cuz I know guys that love like
it you from / - fair you were one of
them there's love sex yeah I love sex I
love sex but like I'm also lazy yeah I'm
also lazy yeah so those times I ended up
[ __ ] so many girls because they as
accessible he was accessible for one
we've already decided talk to girls yeah
so for some reason all these girls want
to talk to me I don't talk to anyone
yeah so it was easy I don't have to do
anything it would literally be like that
approached me we'd talk for a second
either I buy them a drink there buy me a
drink we'll talk for another second as
I wouldn't see them until the end of the
night and where they grabbed him he said
coming back coming back wave you've been
on our block where you been tonight
you're coming back all this stuff yeah
yeah so a lot of times the only reason
why I went prove it and there's a cup of
tea there's loads of funny times
there was a time the oh ah let me think
I'll go straight to the tip of the
iceberg yeah it's very funny now at the
time it was like I literally felt like
Joey from friends it was a point where
towards the back end of this like
three-month stint yeah I [ __ ] him
[ __ ] and [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] my way through the entire uni
pretty much and then I saw a guy I think
it was just me and you I saw a girl I'm
like oh she's all right she looked at me
we made eye contact there was a couple
smiles exchanged or whatever yeah I
grabbed a drink went over to her and I
was like as in hush this was in harsh
year I said something like because I
remember she had unbelievable lips yeah
I said to her like your lips are insane
yeah and she was like haha Thanks then I
said what's your name
mmm and she said is that a joke and I
was like what do you mean is that joke
and she was like James is that a joke
and I said how do you know my name
I remember now I think it was the story
going I remember now she said I said how
do you know my name and she was like oh
you're [ __ ] serious and I was like
trying to play it off like I wasn't see
yeah yeah it's very serious yeah and she
was like dude I've got your number in my
phone and she showed me my number and I
was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's
my number yeah and I was like what yeah
and she said my name is beep yeah we
[ __ ] and as soon as she said we [ __ ]
I knew exactly who she was yeah but I
was like oh my [ __ ] god
how am I gonna get out of [ __ ] and I was
like oh yeah I know that I know that I'm
just telling your lips are ba yeah like
I just love your lips so she was like
[ __ ] and I remember I spent that
entire night she eventually forgave me
by members I spent that entire she
didn't go to our unit went to different
unique yeah and she was just visiting a
friend or something yeah we spent that
entire night in her car into a daybreak
that she would not let me hit she was
adamant that we were not [ __ ] yeah
because she was so pissed off but I had
no idea who she was and that was when I
realized like this [ __ ] boy life is
consequential and I was also know what
you do know what are you doing as a
human being but that you've you've had
intercourse with because because at the
same time like it sounds like a super
[ __ ] thing to say but like some of my
exceptional experiences that I've had
have been breathtaking breathtaking you
know with someone that you loved it [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah and you just like like
that's sex that's what sex is about
that's what human beings were made yeah
like [ __ ] hell when your whole body's
just gone yeah and you have no idea how
loud you be but no idea for nothing you
don't give a [ __ ] Brooke you just Dan
you're into it and everything's going
and it's just like what the [ __ ]
sickest thing you've ever experienced
yeah and then I'm like I shared that
with someone yeah and obviously that's
not why I experienced but that's
conceptually speaking that's what we did
yeah and I've just told her to her face
I have no idea and I was like this is
that's the bad yeah that was when it it
got bad for me and it's funny now but
it's also like [ __ ] you now James
[ __ ] hell bro what the [ __ ]
there was I've got millions of these
there was a time where I was [ __ ] one
girl I was [ __ ] one girl well
actually I wasn't in [ __ ] this guy I
was actually seeing this girl and we
were kind of honored but we were super
on and off you know I love my life yeah
wanna go away yeah yeah
but she was crazy yeah she was the
craziest person you've ever met yeah I
bet you're so [ __ ] bar
she was she was amazing she was but
that's all she was yeah it was the
best-looking go one of the best-looking
girls I've ever seen in person yeah
at that time yeah and I was obsessed
over there anyway
I was kind of seeing her on and off yeah
she was pissed off at me about something
so she decided to take her crazy ass
over to my house in the middle of the
night bang down one bethis bang down the
door and it's because she spoke to you
yeah she spoke to you yeah said that
I've heard James has said this yeah you
guys spoke about it I was like what the
[ __ ]
and then she said to you something about
where the [ __ ] is he yeah and you and I
don't know probably at home so she
walked all the way to our house banging
down the door God knows what time it was
in the morning Aaron opened the door she
barged pass him stormed her straight up
to my bedroom and flipped the sheets
because she thought I was in bed but I
wasn't there cuz I was [ __ ] [ __ ]
saved you [ __ ] saved you imma have to
go in the good category that might have
to [ __ ] save you
that's funny oh it's crazy it's crazy
man and there's all kinds of [ __ ]
there's the [ __ ] please k so I had
the other day this is the [ __ ] time
that I had to basically a [ __ ] buddy
yeah and we used to [ __ ] yeah we used to
[ __ ] smash oh and she was louder than
loud loudest loud far out and she had a
high-pitched voice she used to scream
this is an a.m. yeah I was in bed yeah
and this room was above mine yeah I my
room was directly above for yets and
then we finish up everything's all good
and I can't remember what you said I
look down at my phone and I've got a
text that's just something like thank
you thank you for that thank you for
that like we came at the same time I
gather my man is using this girl's
vocals as spank bank
spank back material I was sweet because
I need a laugh and you better laugh so
hard I knew you could hit up
laughs so I was rolling around in bed
and there was another time I don't know
if I've said this on the podcast before
but there was another time when we lived
in a five bedroom house was five of us
yeah and yes so it was me if you had
obviously our friend Aaron friend Jacob
who was on the podcast not long ago
another friend Toby towles and me and
Toby basically shared a room so
basically that we had an attic
conversion and there was a very thin dry
wall that separated the room so as you
could tell when they designed the house
they in order to make it for students
that take in this attic room put this
[ __ ] little drywall between it and where
to bird made it two bedrooms so they
could fit more people in their tiny
little rooms but I didn't give a [ __ ] so
we're doing nothing me and this girl
just finished up and just we've been his
[ __ ] we'd been [ __ ] I think I know
is yeah so we've been [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah and then she knew that Toby had the
room on the other side of the wall yeah
and she was so paranoid and she was just
like ah he sure he can't hear us in
there you sure like knows like the hall
stick don't worry about him I hear his
[ __ ] and then I was I don't worry about
babes it's all good yeah and it's just
are you sure you sure like I'm so
paranoid lucky enough to see him in the
morning don't even worry about he come
his [ __ ] she was like okay okay and then
all simmered and we stopped talking and
all year is just I've never seen anyone
go red so fast that little clear of his
throat it was it she liked and it
sounded like what I can hear you yeah it
was clear as day and I was [ __ ]
hissing I was [ __ ] pissing myself
bro and he's literally all it was was
for fun yeah all it was it wasn't even
necessarily about the sex yeah yeah it
wasn't about the girls
it was all about the fun times at the
moment what I can go downstairs in the
morning yeah around the breakfast table
and tell the fellas about the
funny [ __ ] like crazy [ __ ] there's
[ __ ] times where I thought to go I
thought I thought I met a gun out this
is when we were all drinking drinking we
went on a night out we would drink and
drinking and I got crazy drunk crazy
quick I don't know if I hadn't eaten or
whatever crazy drunk crazy quick and
then this girl approached me literally
early on in the night was like are you
coming back yeah and I was I [ __ ] it
let's go I was so drunk went back to
hers in the middle of bulls deep action
my tummy's feeling a bit mm-hmm and I'm
like [ __ ] so we [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and
again my tummy's feeding and you know
when the rooms feeling as well and I was
like babe I don't think I can carry on
yeah this room is [ __ ] spinning like
a field dodgy like I don't think we can
finish this and she's alright cool
am i closing on the side of the bed and
I'm like cool let me just rest my head
so yeah he lying on the room is spinning
you look to the side
yeah rune spinnin look to the side and I
[ __ ] him puke yeah all over my clothes
that I've just parked on the side of the
floor I just remember - this is okay
Sydney yeah puked all over my [ __ ]
clothes out on the floor yeah and I'm
like [ __ ] she's on that she's on my
hands and knees scrubbing the floor yeah
and I'm just a [ __ ] you know and I'm
asked native and her housemate comes
upstairs as well and helps her clean
this up and I'm butt-naked starkers yeah
and I'm not cool man I should probably
offer to help obviously I was naked in
trunk drunk yeah and I was like [ __ ]
alright um and I just said like I need
to go yeah and then she gave me her
dad's pyjamas go home in yep her dad
must be 4 foot zip because my mom's full
length trousers were like he half way
Shin his full length t-shirt was like he
elbowed just below and I'm war in his
day like yeah it must've been my 6 a.m.
yeah and I'm walking all the way through
commentary yeah in this midgets [ __ ]
pajamas yeah looking like a [ __ ] and I
made it to our house and I'm
you know down on the door and you had
the bomb floor and you would not wake
the [ __ ] up I'm a deep sleeper cuz and
people don't work people go work up and
down the street and I'm just banging
down this door looking like a [ __ ] yeah
boy it was atrocious man it was soo many
times a time I stole a girl's money ask
sake home you've got stories but and the
stories and the stories yeah let me get
to this one real quick is the last one
so again
mad girl and I already knew her I think
yeah I knew this girl we'd slept with
each other a couple times the same girl
no smart no money one no the pajama girl
was I know you do one is I think anyway
the money
yeah the pajama girl and who do you
think the drama goes where do they live
I don't know but did not live in
Coventry then even that round you yeah
okay cool money girl was outfit girl we
cool
so yeah [ __ ] you know it's so crazy that
we know what we're talking about it
clicks it's embarrassing because through
the insight we've used so many aliases
and nicknames yeah that when you tell me
someone's real name I don't know who the
[ __ ] they are here it's crazy
he's disgust but where mum let me have
another sip sip before I get to the
story I thought you know where boys [ __ ]
you know we've been boys for a minute
now Jesus Christ I love my life so do I
so do i oh
quick segue while we're pouring this
drink yeah for the listeners yeah and
the viewers we are trying to well we've
been trying to find an anime up so we
want to turn some of our stories we'll
animate some of our stories to add to
the comedic effect and I'm actually
having a bit trouble find a cartoonist
or anime or whatever so if anyone is an
anime or knows one yeah please send them
to our Instagram DM box and help us out
please so much free tools and if you do
and we find out me security
to give you a shelter Oh we'll give you
a shout-out yeah man for sure we'd give
you a cello right
what's his shot number three four four
maybe who knows who's counting
sip sips [ __ ] me anyway so the story
would the money go yeah so as I was
saying me and this girl we've been
sleeping together he's a bit harsh
because I knew she had stronger feelings
as you know I don't feel bad because she
made out like she didn't I knew deep
down that she did yeah she was adamant
that she didn't yeah and would try her
darndest to make me believe that she
didn't yeah so that's on her I don't
feel bad [ __ ] it so we were sleeping
together very rarely yeah
very rarely once if we very on and off
yet yeah very on very very on enough in
anyway it's Halloween we all go out and
we wear in we just we couldn't find a
costume or we left it too late to get a
costume so we all wore these white
shirts with like this is what we work
for Butler's so me and foo you had had
our Butler attire yeah
so we wear war bow ties yeah from work
yeah cuff links from work and we found a
white shirt tore it out we put lipstick
all over it and I don't know what we
were trying to be but just man who was
apparently yeah so went out looking at
pre experts Halloween whatever [ __ ] you
[ __ ] it so we go out have a good time
you get too drunk and get taken home
early standard standard I bump into this
girl that I sleep with ad hoc and as you
do she invites me back go back to her
house and Bob's your uncle wake up in
the morning emphasis cuz usually when
I'm even if I'm drunk or whatever my
body will wake me up at like 9 or 10 no
matter what doesn't matter if we went to
bed at 6:00 doesn't matter with seven
nine or 10 my body's waking me up
I could be collapsed drunk and it's
doing it the only other time they didn't
do is at Leeds time
my [ __ ] hip was hoeing anyway so
Bob's your uncle we [ __ ] we slept
these times I wake up I'm gonna all
right cool I'm super parched go to the
toilet or go to the kitchen get a drink
go for a piss whatever go back into the
bedroom check my phone and it's like
2:00 in the afternoon and I was like
holy [ __ ] and this girl lived right on
campus Yeah right [ __ ] on so you
could open a front door and their
students was walking left right
everywhere so I looked out the front
window and I'm seeing everyone yeah and
I was like [ __ ] yeah I've only got my
[ __ ] Halloween outfit yes tonight
so she's fast asleep I'm for some reason
I'm panicked I've got no cash on me
I'm the closest cashpoint atm whatever
you want to call it is down the road
further into campus and I [ __ ] that like
that completely
she's obviously a girl she lives with
girl she ain't got no clothes she can
lend me so as I'm sweating thinking
about how I'm gonna patent this trip
home and look over to a dresser and I
see five policy in there I'm like okay
bingo bingo that's getting on so well
Greta bleah if she's listening highly
doubt she is she's look regrettably yes
I stole the five pounds I confess I
confess because I didn't hide it when
she asked it me I stole the five pounds
called a taxi and yeah called the taxi
got taken home and it was all good later
on she messaged me this is this is where
I actually felt bad
later on she messages me and was like oh
did you see five pound on my dresser
like I can't find it and I was like oh
no five five five what pounds sterling
knobby now babe I didn't you know she's
oh okay
[ __ ] are you sure you didn't see it are
you sure you didn't take it by accident
this time she was probably awake yeah
she's probably awake and saw me [ __ ]
nap and it was just too polite to say
she so
I know I didn't see you know I'm really
sorry I didn't see any 5-pound did
definitely take it she was I cool no
worries and I'm like if he need five
pound I can send you five pound that's
my problem
she's like yeah this is really
embarrassing but I do need that five
pound that was actually like my last
five pounds yeah and I'm like [ __ ] you
know I'm like alright cool my send you
me about details are slide five found in
there easy easy
and I'm [ __ ] hungover that yeah I
didn't want to leave the house so I was
like give me your account details I put
it in your account right now and that's
not a problem she's like yeah that's the
problem that is the problem my accounts
now in is overdrawn so if you put fire
pound in there it's just gonna get it's
just gonna go straight into that yeah
and I won't be here to take it out can
you come and meet me give me five pound
I feel bad this is where I feel bad
because I was so hungover that I was
like [ __ ] that and I just ignored her I
don't know she ate that day I don't know
if she got to lectures
I didn't know what she needed that five
pound for oh my she didn't get it from
me and I feel so guilty to this day that
it was however many years ago and I
stole the [ __ ] five pounds of I can't
get home never gave it back because I
was too lazy to leave the house and what
made it [ __ ] worse was when Aaron
said to me bro why didn't you just order
the taxi knock on the door take five
pounds from one of us and pay the taxi
man yeah straight I don't think straight
man I just stole the money
but yeah bro I've got a million stories
I've always said I'm gonna write a book
so when this body takes off maybe I'll
write a book about my fuck-boy days the
air and there's so much good so much bad
so much funny so much fun so much funny
but it's more funny than but I do think
the funny definitely outweighs the good
and the bird for sure for the story man
their stories are whereas atmospheres
are the basis of this podcast do you
remember the time you all got laid and I
was in the pink the pink came to pick
you up
yeah in the pink
you look like you stepped out from when
cheers I remember taking pictures on my
phone and you genuinely looked like you
stepped out of the scene Oh Cheers
open the door your face was turning do
you remember when we saw that same go in
the library library and she sat
stretched she clear-- didn't know who
you were sat there she sat next to us I
looked at her and I looked to you ha ha
ha ha um she was here James was there I
looked at her I looked at James I was
like rah you know what's funny about her
mmm you know what's actually hilarious
about her well she's ugly and trash yeah
but you could definitely [ __ ] like I
hold no animosity because I would know
yeah there's certain about what so ever
you definitely [ __ ] yeah she's got
that trash vibe I was actually listen to
a podcast about this the other day and
they were saying about like the
difference between a girl being
beautiful and a girl being hot yeah and
like why guys are attracted to just sex
like what looks like set yeah and
basically if you take it down to its
like genetic format it's that it's a way
cuz basically obviously all males from
all species pretty much apart from like
[ __ ] penguins or Sian ah designed to
just spread seed yeah
spread seed and the way humans are wired
if you find like you like most people do
when you find the one when you find your
missus is very rare that you just met
her on a night out [ __ ] er yeah and
then you married her yeah I guess rare
yeah and if you did do it it's destined
for disaster yeah so um when you our
brains after thousands of millions of
years of evolution our brains are wired
that when you see because it's different
like when you see a woman that's
beautiful yeah she could be stunning
yeah it doesn't make you horny he
doesn't make you wanna [ __ ] you don't
wanna [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you just gorgeous
I'll do anything for you yeah yeah it
doesn't make you horny yeah when you see
someone trashy yeah they might not even
be [ __ ] they might not even be
objectively good-looking but you see
them you see legs you see
tits you see ass and you know I wanna
[ __ ] ya so apparently the theory is
that's genetically wired so that it's we
see that yeah and we think okay perfect
this is an opportunity for me to spread
my DNA without like quickly without
taking much time into it yeah so you see
that person you see that they're freeing
up the skin yeah and you're like bang
let me bust it's not spread my DNA and
then I can move one yeah hopefully I'll
find the one yeah if not I'll bust my
yeah yeah keep busting one up until I
find the one that I'm ready to have lots
of kids with yes that way I can make
sure that my DNA is sorted yeah until I
find the one and apparently that's the
theory behind it and it makes sense
because yeah when you see a girl that
just looks swaggy you want you yeah you
just wanna [ __ ] her like you're not you
don't even find anything about a
consequence you don't even think about
anything you just [ __ ] fish and then as
soon as it was episode 1 episode 2 post
nut clarity post wedding in a welfarist
boss that deep worse thing you know what
the [ __ ] have I just done yeah what the
[ __ ] I need to go I need to be out I'm
not buying it it's the scariest
realization as a human being the things
as well um like it happens hmm you not
anything oh [ __ ] you know and women will
never understand like what obviously
when you're like I want to leave yes
like I told you there's been times in my
life where I think I spoke about outfit
girl yeah but she put on that outfit
yeah she sent me a picture yeah said
calm [ __ ] yeah I went over there [ __ ]
her yeah
she then and then I got dressed and was
ready to leave and she was outwardly
stained she was pissed off that I'm not
saying it sucks that women will never
ever ever understand that it's just it's
DNA this making me not want to stay yeah
like I genuinely thought like there's
been times where like you can meet a
girl especially when you're drunk you
can meet a go you start talking to her
anything me especially I'm the worst
breath yeah I love this [ __ ] yeah
you've seen me and I'm like bro if she's
Peng yeah I love this [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] a loafer yeah she's so
interesting she's a she's a receptionist
yeah ah a dentist yeah she's so
interesting yeah because I'm seeing tits
yeah and then I [ __ ] her and as soon as
I [ __ ] her I'm like so
see you later she thinks I'm an [ __ ]
she thinks I was lying yeah she thought
like wow he pretended to be interested
in me this whole time so we could [ __ ]
not true I generally was interested I
just didn't know it was my dick that was
interested more than I put more than my
head at my heart I thought I was into
you I thought I wanted us to have kids
but now I've got that post nut clarity
it turns out I don't actually like you
to be boring
I'm gonna bounce they'll never
understand what it means every single
man on planet earth knows 100% they
don't know what we're talking about
hundreds are they oh no
anyone who says they don't know is a
liar liar as soon as you not you're like
like Rocky now don't touch me don't
touch me don't kiss me don't hug be get
off I want to get dressed
yeah I want to be true I want a piece
dressed dressed and go home this rest
and go don't even want to get in the
boat to go home I just want to be loved
yeah why am I here I want to be home
there's been times where I've literally
sprinted home to name a few there's been
times where I've had that postnup
clarity got immediately dressed as soon
as I got out the door I ran at home I
needed to be hon I needed to forget just
what happened I know once I was living
that's funny
anyway man rapid e-wrap not yet Oh story
I've already noticed any sips it burst
now I'm gas there's never been a time
where I've said shall we wrap and you
said no give me that give me that
oh I feel we should do drop pods me off
and I know well say that we might get
post drunk clarity
yeah erase this whole thing it's been in
the pine apps
drunken ages are happy bro I haven't
drank in ages either I just [ __ ] you
know what I do in me please
Oh holy [ __ ] what he needs to slide this
this way cuz you want like very cutout
am I on an off cam yeah that's so much
better
so much bar bro you tell me that we're
about an hour in I know I know but I
thought you cause I thought you realize
I just thinking [ __ ] I can't see I can't
actually see the thing for me okay
anyway carry almost that worried so I'm
gonna tell the story I'm finally gonna
tell the story on the on the pot I
didn't even know what's - I know I'm
gonna say one go I'm gonna geek oh the
trifecta the try the reason it's called
a trifecta will come to fruition
alright take your time once I say story
take your time said understand walk us
through the entire first and wise call
the traffic so flashback back to
University this is the idea we're all
living together all five of us as we
said before myself my boy James REM a
Kay Aaron J a cage a cub tops a K Toby
so the year before that DS man had gone
to carnage so it's a rave it's a white
rate basically essentially some soccer
crews a Barker who's [ __ ] amazed and
this was way before sorry this was way
before I had ever gone to any white
rooms I was always always going to the
RMB raise all this now it never used to
it's a house raves nine because I'm
thinking that's not me it's just not me
and then these men would always go
always say is sick and always clean up I
think it [ __ ] it this year I'm gonna go
so all of us we buy the tea's is like
ten pound it to you get different colors
or whatnot your Gatti's the day comes
um gassed your gum gasps don't you think
yes okay I'm gassed let's go let's go
let's go me now being an idiot not
knowing at the time
I backed two or bottle and a half
amaretto clean you're like obviously it
might not sound straight it might not
sound that harsh are that strong but
when I say a bottom on half I literally
mean one of these and a half of amaretto
no chaser none Lita
I was down in it so the alcohol content
obviously the Cure so the alcohol
contents program
27% for example but get down in a bottle
in half it's a knife you know you know
it's a night butter sauce that but I was
in my element means it was blasting
everyone was getting ready I was vibing
so from my house or our house rather to
our boys house that we're going to his
apartment was about less than a five
minute walk like literally I could two
minute what was like two minute walk I
stumbled onto a car and laid out flat
like you know when you're doing what's
the finger minutes not snow angels I was
told we still got the picture on his
phone to this day so with this day on
the Koch hole stood up baby went into
our boys flat his name's Jeremy went
into his flat with chillin chillin now I
weren't eyebrows flat
he was Stevens it was Stephen Jay some
random foreign go and some other people
jabberin Jaron did not live there okay
Stephens flat yeah II before yeah yeah
Stephens flat okay and I we're all
talking laughing getting ready right at
it and I'm feeling so queasy and I'm
thinking scam on Rev I knew what was
going on the reason why I knew what was
going on because in it was called Kyle
escort where where they lived there was
obviously because he was a high-rise
their windows didn't open that far yeah
sorry oh but it was like a jar when I
say your jobs like probably this much my
mouth fit through it vomited Oh
sixteenth I remember and I saw it just
trickled out I was done this is going on
about seven eight years ago oh yeah
probably more than that yeah Don I threw
a pass Fink in London I don't know if
I'm making it out tonight yeah like I
was thinking you've been sick now yeah
the worst is over this is over I'm fine
cool so I was chillin chillin chillin on
the sofa everyone's like yeah let's go
we're ready
I was like man damn I don't I don't
think I can do it like what you mean
what do you mean was just like man I
just don't think I can do it I know that
okay let's take you home
like I said bearing in mind it was like
a two minute walk from mine or from yeah
mine too my boys and again back from my
boys too - a two-minute walk they tried
to pick me up from the sofa to get to
their front door they couldn't leave I
can do it
they couldn't me nothing like RAM and
Jimmy sighted side-to-side couldn't move
Jacob was on the back picking you up so
there was three of us trying to pick URI
dead weight is probably like the weight
of an elephant bro don't move honest to
god the heaviest thing of every my mind
couldn't comprehend the physics my mind
cannot comprehend the physics how this
guy can be walking and talking on a
normal day to day basis but three fully
grown men can't pick him up
my dad way you were the heaviest person
but it didn't make any sense I was you
were smaller than you were [ __ ] heavy
you keep trying I need a piss so yeah he
was going there trying to pick me up
trying to pick me up and it was just it
just wasn't happening it just wasn't
happening at all James has gone to the
toilet by the way for the viewers and
listeners just what's happening at all
just what's happening so they tried to
they kept on trying kept so try and kept
trying it just was happening okay cool
do you know what we'll leave you here
we'll leave you at the flat so you can
rest and you know recoup I'm like to be
fair I'm probably not even responsive I
can hear them but I'm probably not
trying anything because this is probably
the worst I've ever been in my adult
career of drinking and that was probably
the start of my adult career drinking
like I I hate drinking because of that
because of that experience so remember
the story's called trifecta so I'm lying
there sleeping or wherever and I think
before then man all go out Stevie leaves
a bucket just in case but a bucket next
to me one line out just in case I need
to throw up obviously because for me to
stand up and throw out throw up by the
window would be effort for me so Steve
you for watching this or listening I
spied you for that thank you
God it could have been Stevie could have
been Junior
remember either one I spud you for that
because you you looked off the man that
day this is where it gets interesting
so I now then wake up in the middle
light obviously as you do you throw up
you throw you throw up and then the
thing with me is that I've got a funny
stomach when I drink I need to like
release everything especially well if
I've gone over one and that night I went
[ __ ] overboard so I'm throwing up a
throwing up a thrown up I go to bed so
let me give you a bit of context cuz I
said it was color school says the
student combination so bearing in mind I
was chilling in like the liver room like
the commuter area and each it was bright
car five bedroom lock but each room is
locked yeah you have to have a key card
to get in so I had no access to like a
an actual toilet a bar from nothing I
was just in the community area which is
a living room in the kitchen so that's
why the reason that's the reason why he
gave me the bucket make sense
cool throwing up throwing up throwing up
went back to bed I'm thinking but I need
to [ __ ] I'm thinking [ __ ] I need to
[ __ ] [ __ ] because throw it up isn't
helping mine use the bucket I can't
imagine you squatting over this sick
filled bucket it was a mop I remember
mop bucket with the black mesh I
remember I remember
so even over that little bit chaos I
didn't care cuz I needed to feel bad you
know obscene like I said I only had a
hopper right so I hadn't eaten I
probably have eaten since like lecture
time I knew that because you started
drinking from like 5 p.m.
early from like dusk I was drinking you
were drinking from early early drinking
so I my ship was running like it wasn't
that a solid ship where you know you can
feel like yeah I'm getting liar it was
it was coming a lot that's the scoop now
you know I couldn't be any more now and
I just wasn't getting any better
I wasn't feeling any better I was like
but obviously when I'm not obviously pop
when I share a piss at the same time so
hence the story trifecta so yeah so tuck
your dick in that little spaces or and I
pissed in a bucket that's why it's
called a trifecta story but what's even
so much more funny than that is when
these men came back from the night out
to pick me up obviously I was a bit more
a bit more alert because I flushed all
out my system I just dipped with them I
never told him I did what I did I saw
the day after so I don't even know ever
damn man saw the bucket oh that's funny
you know it's funny as well I Stephen
never mentioned it no one ever mentioned
that bucket no one ever mentioned it
like that bucket could still be there I
don't know you know what I'm gonna do
I might probably won't put this I don't
know man I brought maybe I'll make the
clip maybe I won't I'll see how you feel
posted at a time but I will make a clip
yeah I'm gonna send it to Stephen yeah
question mark I want to know if he knew
what went down
or maybe that polite little foreign girl
just scurried in saw a bucket full of
[ __ ] piss and vomit and fought let me
clear this out maybe who knows who knows
let me clear this out but she didn't
even go out she was there the whole time
I remember she was there the whole time
but if it's what I would have give I
would have pay serious big boy money for
her to walk in while you're [ __ ] in
this bag I know you wouldn't have given
a [ __ ] fam but if I could be a fly in
the wall that she was screamed shoot
them shoulda streamed everyone oughta go
to jail a sign I would have gone to
somewhere like funniest [ __ ] story
today was the day I'd give him an the
story one of the most embarrassing
things
happened to be my entire life a man but
you know tis what is that's why school
shit's and gigs we move almost a decade
that was almost a [ __ ] decade ago now
we can wrap up now we can wrap let me
let's do one more shot for good for good
luck before we wrap this as always guys
like subscribe comment we get a lot of
love in kind of Instagram mostly to be
honest in person as well we get a lot of
my personal phone number blows up but as
I've said before the day the day of
YouTube subscriptions is is dying low
yeah
and that's fine as I said before I don't
subscribe to [ __ ] on YouTube because
YouTube just suggests the [ __ ] that I
like yeah if I follow it if I like if
I've watched a few things off a certain
channel I will just get suggestions I
don't even subscribe to it cuz it just
gives me the next video anyway yeah but
guys obviously we're looking for
subscribers we want to carry this on we
want to do this for life it's you if you
Leia if you man like kidding and
subscribed and yet keep the keep the
dream role in if there's any obviously
as always if there's anything you want
to hear yeah yeah man this is my it's
coming soon my deepest darkest secret it
might have to be another tequila night
my deepest darkest secrets come in
coming soon imma have to get drunk as
[ __ ] but it's definitely coming so give
us the love guys give us the hate if
he's what you prefer but just take this
last Akita sip sip guys if you hit up
the ticky to sip sip and you like or you
don't like let us know send us a
instagrams the main method for us right
I'm is the main
main main method man hit us up Instagram
shit's and gigs on the school podcast
comment on the YouTube if it's easier if
you [ __ ] just listen to the show
don't go on YouTube don't have any crime
don't have to wear hip meet up or hit me
a hip us up
what's the email address shit's and gigs
no egg so [ __ ] the way it spelt as [ __ ]
and gigs at gmail.com I've got so many
[ __ ] stories brother you decided to
talk about my Instagram underscore if
you hid on the school James is James
Duncan underscore live I think we can I
think we can attack another boy you know
that look really loose alright let's try
the sip sip and hit this redeem
ourselves topic nights out nights out
clubs dance girls whatever nights out
that's the topic no for spin lyrics it's
just me I'm a hit you man what science
equal while it's not listening so cut
laugh at me here we go here we go nights
out I'm a nice guy I hate fights out if
a man tried test then it's lights out
[ __ ] you know couple [ __ ] out they be
speights out that doesn't make sense
flying kites out through years trifecta
shites out if she's looking good I might
bites out what else rhymes with bites
I just might shout
please hurry up phone comeback changing
the rhyming word cuz it's evenings out
hate condoms there's no she things out
[ __ ] you know when I'm hyped up it's big
breathing's out if hang on I wanna roll
if you piss me off I might leave it out
leave it out
finish strong imma heave it out if we're
talking pets then I'm peeving out when
I'm really a vex I'm a screamer shout
[Laughter]
scream and shout we even bought I might
start screamin stop
beef is hot cook it up a knot in the pot
sweep it up but I might use a mop to
clean it up
I'm lazy so I'll leave a lot speak with
an accent but I'm not a Scot II Scott
when it comes to WWE I'm Scotty 2 hotty
your girl on my D like she's 30 Mac
thorry
we've been sippin on a tequila a
pineapple
[Music]
away hang on hang on I'm gonna hit a
double-barrel like I'm holding Shoei hmm
I'm a real guy you won't see me buddy
hmm
I hit it with the cross but I'm playing
naughty Naut some cross mmm
playing games it shit's and gigs no
times and names huh aliases only we
stick to the script
you fake [ __ ] can't phone me I can
feel your needy there there there's
magic happening there's [ __ ] magic
happening there's [ __ ] magic yes go
let's go go one more shot one more shot
I missed this let it flow let it flow
[Music]
leggo
no frozen said her name's Elsa is that
it okay it's funny because there's
literally one less than I left everyone
at the one is definitely gonna be one
listener left to now everyone's tuned
the [ __ ] out you know what you know
what's funny about it it went so well
yeah and so funny yeah somehow it got
too serious yeah we got to invest before
we were we fought with lyrical it was
that last shot we were there like quick
quick my palms are sweaty knees weak
arms heavy bombing on a sweater already
mom's spaghetti a
he was a long episode but thank you guys
this is this is beyond fun there's some
times I'll be honest man when I'm
feeling waved I get open sometimes like
I think I've explained it before by
explaining for the newbies like in order
for us to produce this podcast like her
I Drive or he comes down it's a
three-hour trip it's an effort and I'm
making FM we we make as much as we can
yeah but yeah I'm not gonna lie to you
guys as times where I like this morning
for example I've had a [ __ ] night's
sleep I Drive three hours all the way up
here and by the time I get here
sometimes I'll just want to chew on my
boy I can't be above this up the mics I
can't be both to set up the software I
can't be bothered to get the camera
ready I come over to make sure the
batteries are charged I can't be
bothered to make sure the wires aren't
in view I can't be bothered to make sure
the Lighting's right I can't be bothered
to do all these things because it's such
a process but as soon as the cameras
rolling as that camera he let me hit
required I'm there with flowing flowing
for you you know like obviously we do
this like we love doing what we do like
that's the thing I heard this on another
shout to Chris D'Elia so crystally as a
comedian in America he's got a podcast
called congratulations so yeah he's
funny as [ __ ] if you if you like comedy
check it out shout to Chris but he said
a profound thing he doesn't know it's
profound but he said like this podcast
can't happen without his fans and then
he stopped and was that actually it can
happen without his fans it would just be
him walking around his house talking
[ __ ] because that pockets just him it
just runs yeah you've seen it so he
would say this podcast can happen there
just be no camera more no microphone and
be him walking around his house and it's
exactly the same for [ __ ] gigs this
podcast has been happening for the last
11 years we just chat we say yeah
on-camera the same [ __ ] we say to each
other
the only difference is I bought a camera
I bought microphone and I bought the
software we want to share with you man
because before you man will find a fun
experiences man we laughed I've known
this boy since 2009 it's not 2020 it's
been a trip it's been a trip mom and 31
countries say that our stories are kind
of funny so let's put an ego aside guys
help us out we love doing this so yeah
this club
keep it poppin monk we love doing this
right
rat brats see you guys soon